rojo
miles de afganos se agolpan a las
afueras del aeropuerto de kabul
intentando salir del país al menos siete
personas murieron este domingo en medio
del caos según el ministerio de defensa
del reino unido y la otan calcula que 20
fallecieron en la última semana por
disparos o por estampidas el talibán
responsabiliza a eeuu de generar el
desorden
la gente se está congregando alrededor
del aeropuerto internacional de kabul
porque porque eeuu dijo ven aquí te
llevaremos a eeuu nombre un país en el
que la gente no haría eso ante tal
anuncio en bajo os va a abrir la casa
blanca en cambio habla de la posibilidad
de que aliados del autodenominado estado
islámico ataquen a quienes quieren huir
la amenaza de real es aguda es
persistente y es algo en lo que estamos
enfocados con cada herramienta de
nuestro arsenal al respecto del
presidente joe biden explicó que
extendieron el perímetro de seguridad
para acceder al aeropuerto y que el
talibán cooperó con esto
el contexto de seguridad está cambiando
rápidamente hay civiles asignados en el
aeropuerto aunque ya evacuamos a miles
de ellos sabemos que los terroristas
pueden aprovechar la situación y atentar
contra afganos inocentes o tropas
estadounidenses con cruise muestra de
que la situación empeora es que miles ya
huyeron del país eeuu asegura que ha
evacuado a 33.000 personas reino unido a
5000 italia 2100 la unión europea a
cerca de 300 personas
india 250 ucrania 83 e indonesia a 33
hasta las aerolíneas privadas se están
contribuyendo como la de bahrein maiden
pidió a las compañías comerciales que
voluntariamente transporten hacia sus
destinos finales a quienes abandonaron
kabul en aviones militares